what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 16th of june
welcome to uncle joey's joint the joint
is brought to you by
zip recruiter listen everybody's getting
these unemployment checks nobody wants
to go to work good help is hard to find
you can't it's too tough right now it's
like trying to find
a [__] peanut on the beach you're in
no danger
you could always post your job online on
the cork board at the laundromat
but who the [__] hangs out of
laundromats bums then you gotta sit
there and hope the right person walk by
and seize it
listen stop dreaming try zip recruiter
for free
you're like joey what the hell zip
recruiter they do
the work for you with one click your job
gets sent
over to over a hundred top job sites get
qualified candidates fast
let them play matchmakers so you don't
have to loosen you up more to do
what you need to do you understand me
2.3
million businesses have already used
ziprecruiter
so why are you sitting there going i
need good help go to zip recruiter
right now download it you don't download
it while other companies overwhelm you
with too many options
zip recruiter finds what you're looking
for
that little [__] peanut in the beach
so right now you can try
ziprecruiter for free troy what are you
talking about free
free at ziprecruiter.com
joey again that's ziprecruiter.com
joey find the quality candidate fast
and they're gonna be [__] tremendous
you understand me zip recruit is so
effective
that four out of five employees use
ziprecruiter to get a quality candidate
within the first we'll get
a quality candidate within the first day
that's what i'm talking about saving you
time so do me a favor right now
try ziprecruiter for free at
slash ziprecruiter.com again that's
ziprecruiter.com
joey try it for free just by going to
joey zip recruit is the smartest way to
hire
the joint is also brought to you by one
of my personal favorites i will not let
them go
cbd lion i have gotten more from cbd
line than
any other i mean from the cbd tablets
to the cbd hem flower you got to try it
you gotta [__] try it the vapor pen
the back balls the cream the tape
they have if listen just go to
cbdlion.com
look at this read read about what they
have to offer you
this is beautiful you've never seen
anything like this
they even tell you what to recommend the
sense
the size and strength if you want to
give it to your pet they have
the flavors and potential benefits they
got shatter
they got vape cartridges they got
distillate vape
pens flavored tinctures listen but it
all starts
by you going to cbdlion.com
and reading the types of cannabinoids
and how
cannabinoids and how they could help you
so right now go to cbdline.com right now
preston joey or church and get 20
off delivered right to your
[__] crib all right
it's that simple cbd lion
has been with me for years and they came
through
with my surgery if you see i'm out of
[__] tape
i got that one little row left because
that tape is tremendous when i would go
to the gym so right now
go to cbdline.com read you find
something
try the tablets they'll point you to
what you need
cbdlion.com now it's time
to get this [__] party started
we got a great episode for you today
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here on a beautiful
wednesday june the 16th we're halfway
out of this
[__] as you can tell i'm looking
a lot better i'm feeling a lot better
that little chitchat with the therapist
i chit-chatted with her twice already
and i feel a lot better
uh we came to the conclusion that it was
my thyroid medication ever since
listen since i've moved here i've
elevated my
you know i was going to like kickboxing
and
jiu jitsu once a week but with the
weights i've been hitting them four
times a week
and i even lost weight during the
[__] uh
surgery when i was laid up how could
you're not burning any calories you're
just laying on a chair
i thought it was a strict diet but when
i looked at the numbers the numbers were
going really low
so my wife came to i've had a rough
[__] couple days here with my wife
and stuff not
us going at each other i was trying to
figure out
what the [__] is wrong with me you know
i had like uh
my heart beat the other day was so bad
you could see it in my stomach
just the shirt somebody was sitting next
to me my wife and she goes i can feel
your heart
what is going on with you you know so we
brought the
i checked my blood pressure two times a
[__] day that's what you need to do
i've been doing it for years and uh i
[__] brought it downstairs now
and she goes let me see what your blood
pressure's like when you're just sitting
down and it was
perfect and then i started getting
anxiety
and that's when i told my heart's like
playing the [__] it sounded like john
bonham doing moby dick i'm sitting there
so i said you know let's do it again and
she goes your blood pressure's perfect
but your pulse is down your pulse is way
down so
i think it's been my thyroid i haven't
been on the medication since friday i
took
myself off it and so far
i'm feeling better the sleep is men's
immense um
i've been working out this morning i
went and drew blood
let's just draw blood and i pissed in a
cup
the worst because you gotta go they
don't even let you drink [__] coffee
so coffee i drink coffee and i don't
start [__] spit pissing in the
morning but
they don't want you to have anything so
i had to go there and they gave me a cup
and they're like you gotta pee
before you [__] uh uh
[__] give blood and i'm like are you
serious
let me give blood let me [__] get all
[__] up a little bit
and then i'll pee and the lady's like no
we insist on it i
had to sit there and then to boot you're
not going to believe this my [__]
ipod
after 20 years went kaput you know how
many [__] songs i got on that ipod
you know how many [__] albums i got
on that ipod i got everything from
[__] bush on there
the [__] mega deck the [__] i got
everything on there all the [__] [__] i
like was on it because of my own
personal nobody can look in there
it's like coming over my house and
looking at my arms and my ipod
you know you know if you change your
mind
in attendance line i had iba dancing
queen
i had all [__] on there i just you know
it was a plane it was i i
used my ipod on the plane so i wanted
music that i
wouldn't listen to all the time yeah i
had sabbath and
zeppelin on there and [__] so i'm stuck
i'm like where's my [__] santana
so now i got no santana oye como va
but on my phone i got power rage i got
[__]
uh high and dry and i got something else
and i just put power ray john ac dc
i went in there i put on uh what's next
to the moon
i gave the lady my arm first i had to
pee and that was a [__] nightmare so
i drank like 20 cups of [__] water
right in a row
and still no pee but then i found a
little hindu lady i went up to i said
listen
they want me to [__] pee first i
can't do it let me [__] give you
blood then i'll get scared and then the
natural reaction will be pee
so i went in like nothing gave her the
[__] blood didn't faint i had a
little high injury i
[__] and whatever i put on uh what's
next to the moon
and uh next thing you know i felt the
tape in my arm
i walked out of there and i still
couldn't [__] pee
so i sat there for like five or six
[__] minutes 10 minutes
and finally i kept pushing and pushing
like oh this is because i pee when i
wake up
but this is the second batch this still
has all the minerals in the machine you
know what i'm saying like it's those
it stinks like 10 dead [__] bodies so
i pissed maybe two inches in a [__]
cup and i could smell it
it was [__] awful it smelled like a
fart went bad
i'm saying it's just horrible with the
[__]
blood pressure medication the
testosterone pills the [__]
it's just it's no bueno you know what
i'm saying but uh asparagus
i gave it a [__] i gave it a cup
and that was it now it's i'm waiting for
the doctor to call me
and see what he's got to tell me let's
pray for the best you know what i'm
saying i mean i've been uh
working hard lately and i got flashbacks
today
you know i hate pissing the [__] cup
i [__] hate it
i was looking around and then i thought
there was a mirror on me you know all
those years on probation
me putting [__] in my dick and pissing
and stuff like that
i just got a bunch i was laughing when i
gave the lady my piss i'm like
in the old days i would give her the
probation officer the piss and i'd wait
for it to start bubbling
because there was pool chlorine in there
a [__]
the [__] to clean out your sink oh my
god that was such a horrible time
in my world thank god i got through with
it but we're good man
uh i'm going to a show this week to
watch a comedy show
i acted last week on a movie uh it was
great i felt great [__] doing it you
know
and uh every day is better my house is
[__] solid you know listen man i did
something in the beginning of the
pandemic
me and my i decided that either we would
end up best friends
or we'd end up divorced and i gotta tell
you something that me and my wife
have ended up best best best [__]
friends
you know the other night i thanked her
for making my dreams come true
she helped me become a comic she helped
me become a man
and she gave me a beautiful [__]
daughter that's why i'm here having a
great [__] time
so you know sometimes you gotta
look at the look at somebody from a
different perspective and go wow
if it wasn't for my wife i wouldn't
[__] be here so
we're good man and that's why today
people like
i thought you was my friend called this
morning when i was eating breakfast
and he goes what are you doing like i'm
at the diner eating breakfast but i just
want to give bloody good you wet to give
blood i thought you were [__] scared
of needles i go
listen i'm scared of everything you know
me
i'm scared of [__] everything yeah
and i was watching biloxi blues
great [__] movie 1987. i think it's
neil simon
or woody whatever the guy who [__] the
chinese girl i don't
woody uh
and i think it's neil simon that did
biloxi blues tweet me you know please
don't
i'm not rick ramos i don't know every
[__] producer and every writer
but i was watching biloxi blues and
[__] uh
christopher walken and the guy who
married the chick from sex and the city
and the little jewish guy just
something i don't even know what i was
gonna tell you guys i just been watching
some [__] great movies i don't know
if you watch biloxi blues but there's a
rope there's a part in there where
they got to go to a [__] hooker's
house and
matthew broderick has never been with a
woman before and the [__] hookers
from
her name is rose i i don't even know who
the [__] knows why i even started on
this [__] biloxi blues
what i'm trying to tell you guys is
everything is great we got a great
interview today
uh i you know
i've been podcasting for 10 close to 11
years now
i don't consider myself anything i'm
just a podcaster who's lucky
you know the joint does what it does i
don't sweat it
i'm trying to give a message out some
people i help some people i don't
some people like it some people don't it
doesn't make a ma
difference to me whatsoever some people
moved on god bless you
i'm happy that you moved on whenever you
want to come back you're more than
welcome here
but one guy that never moved on one guy
that i
is a [__] animal is a kid by the name
of cassius morris
i met him 10 years ago when he reached
out and i did his podcast
and i felt so good about
afterward because i was actually
actually helping a kid out
with his dream this was i could tell by
talking to him
that this is what he wanted to do and i
gave him props you know when i was 12 i
didn't know what the [__] i wanted to do
i had no he pinpointed it
and stuck with it and now he's 22.
he's been doing a podcast for 10 [__]
years you know he's a [__]
great media guy and like i told him when
you watch
in 10 years he's gonna be the [__]
king and you you get to see him now
and uncle joey's joint enjoy it
joe diaz what's going on why are you my
little friend been a long [__] time
it has been a long time my man it feels
like we were in different worlds the
last time we talked
i think right at the beginning of the
pandemic
was that long it was that long man but
it's okay
i've been i've been watching you
obviously everybody else has loving it
man you know i've been watching you too
man you had some sensational guests on
there
thank you uh you're doing your thing
you're growing which is what i saw
how old were you when i met you i was
scratching
my head the other night going how old
was i when i went on your podcast first
right and i said a bunch of [__]
stupid [__] and
i left and i'm like how can i talk like
that in front of a 12 year old kid
what the [__] is wrong with me like i
felt like such a [__] douchebag but
then
you became my nephew and i forgave
myself how old were you the first time
we podcasted
i had to be like turning 13.
wow you know and i mean i really
appreciated it joey because you were the
first person to really give me an actual
chance
like that that was the the opening to a
lot of things for me you know and that
was a big chapter in my life when i look
back and think on
that it's uh i can't even really
describe how it feels you know that
somebody gave me a chance like that that
never went over my head just so you know
you know how many [__] chances people
gave me so
when i see a guy online that's on there
every day
busting his ass i reach out you know we
we would stop we started talking we
started complimenting each other you
know
i like that you were a young kid and you
were going after it you knew what you
wanted i think after the first interview
you were talking to me about not going
to school
and yeah l.a stop and you know
just [__] that was uh i was really blown
away
like how much when i was 12
i thought i was going to be a [__]
basketball player but i really didn't
you know what i'm saying like i want to
be a basketball player and an astronaut
you know
the idea is to tell you right but to
really tell somebody when you're 12
years old that you want to be in media
and
you know grow and interview bands and
you know there was two guys
that you guys really blew me away one
was you
and one is the kid from rocking pins
okay yes yes i've watched both of yous
right take off while everybody else
was [__] crying there's a lot of
crying that goes on
well everybody else is [__] crying
nobody gives me nothing
you and mauricio kept pounding it out
pounding
i still remember mauricio paying for
concerts
to take pictures and bringing them to me
at the store
and and telling me like how he had to
sneak in and they threw him out and the
whole thing and then he got a press pass
and he started going to shows now and
then he started writing a blog
to accompany the shows and you know this
is what it is nobody's going to give you
dick
and everybody thinks they're gonna give
you dick nobody's gonna give you dick
go get the [__] you know the other day
some guy hit me up and he's like i want
you to do this this this this and the
on the podcast i go don't you do me a
favor start your own podcast he didn't
even have a podcast and he's emailing
you
no and he's emailing me like barking me
orders and i'm like bro
you have the knowledge on this great guy
don't get me wrong he was a great guy
and you know why i told him to start his
own podcast
because he's got a great story he's a
cancer survivor
which oh wow i know if i had cancer
and i was at home sweating i mean i have
a dear friend right now that's going
through hell
and i want to talk to a cancer survivor
i want to see a guy that made it through
the other side the same way
a guy that went to prison for four years
for a stupid thing looks at me and goes
wait a second
that [__] came out and did
something different with his life
turned his life through it you're a
cancer survivor
you could spread love you could save so
many people and give so many people hope
just by [__] one podcast two podcasts
tell them what you went through the
puking the chemo you know yeah
so it's just uh it's a great thing that
we're doing
it's great that we're still here [__]
pushing doing it it's nice that some
people stick around like obviously you
were always gonna stick around joey but
it's like it's true it's like a rotating
door where
there's not many familiar faces that you
can say okay five six years ago they
were doing a show and stuff it's like
it's constantly changing you know so i
understand what you mean well this
pandemic
made people stay home and yeah i
estimate uh
you know 10 000 new podcasts started
right
especially now but as usual
as per life is
people want to make money and
they don't have the patience if you want
to make money go to the supermarket
stock shelves at night
yeah and then do podcasts in the daytime
and build it up
until it's like comedy it's like uh
being a guitar player it's like
anything else you know go get a [__]
job keep playing your [__] guitar
right
but i work eight to six well you know
you gotta go to on stage from seven to
ten
and exactly that's that's the word and
then
somebody will throw you a bone some guy
will say hey man
uh i do a band and next thing you know
you're making 200 a month
next time you know you're making 400 a
month next thing you know you're making
750 a month you know and now you're like
[__] it now i know what i got to do if i
can make 1100 a month okay that means i
got to get rid of my cable
mm-hmm i got to get for me to live my
dream these are the things i got to
sacrifice
there's so many devices you know it's
incredible i don't even have a tv in
here joey like
in my new spot because i was looking at
tvs and i said
why would i pay hundreds of dollars that
i'm never gonna get back
to waste time i was like let's get real
here because i'm looking around and i'm
like
time is not some like it feels like just
the other day you and me first met
so it's like time is not something that
is that expendable you know what i mean
so it's
it's uh it's it's insane and i feel like
a lot of people they want to talk about
what they want to do they want to watch
videos of bill gates and sit and
fantasize but they don't want to
make moves to make that transition and
i'm sure you've noticed that so much
well it's not that they don't know how
to make moves
i i write it out to the same thing i
have you don't know where to start
yeah that's a big one you don't know
where to start
nobody's there to tell you i got out of
prison
i wanted to do stand-up
you know what are the chances of you
meeting a comedian uh
slim and none you know you get more
chance get hit by a bus
right so i've been meeting a [__]
comedian to help you out
and i was roofing i was frustrated
i it snowed one day and i saw the movie
punchline
with tom hanks and sally struthers not
sally strutz the flying nun
and i i really uh wanted to do stand-up
after that like i was like wait a second
i want to do this and i remember calling
the local comedy club and they're like
oh you got to
come to open mic nights and it just
sounded scary like it
sounded scary and i let it go and then
two months later i'm running an errand
for the company i work for i'm getting
coffee for the boys and
i see an ad in the rocky mountain news
about how to do stand-up comedy
so i i don't i i for some people
it's uh what are the people
procrastinators
exactly yeah and i procrastinated before
i started comedy and for some
people they just really don't know
where to start i could totally see that
and and you know i was one of those
people and
you know one of the most interesting
things for me is because i've like we
talked about like i've been podcasting
since you know i was
however old but the things that were new
to me recently were acting and comedy
actual stand-up and it's so weird i had
this sort of the same
type of urge as you when i went to vegas
right before the pandemic
and i saw like for the first time like
the size of the billboards and like
i sort of saw it with my own eyes where
comedy could take you where acting could
actually take you the fruits of that
labor
and i realized like if i got hit by a
truck tomorrow
and i never tried comedy
that's a pretty tragic thing so like
tragic you know what i mean so i came
home
tried stand up comedy and then within
two months everything was shut down so
it was almost like
i felt like i had to have that under my
belt if it never came back
i did it i just hit me up today
and he said that the local club is
looking for 10 comics and
he's gonna out of respect he's going to
sign up and go down i go listen
even if you never do it again one time
do it again just do it one time get that
rush
or the fear or the diarrhea that squirts
out of here that's the first time how i
seen that bro i wouldn't i
didn't open mike one time where a kid
[__] himself i thought
yeah he was so nervous it was his first
time you know and he [__] up because
he brought like 18 people
i go on stage the first time i don't
bring nobody i didn't tell anybody
no you don't say nothing you know when
you start telling people i'm getting on
stage and 18 people come and you bomb in
front of those 18 people
and then you got to go back to the bar
with your little stupid drink and sit
with them and they don't really want you
sitting at the table it's like people
were
just dressing yeah i don't want you
sitting at the table you just bombed in
front of [__] 80 people
but you know you get on stage you just
it's like when i went to jiu jitsu i
didn't tell
anybody right i went to jiu jitsu for
like two months and got beat up i didn't
tell
anybody i was because that's for you
yeah i was too embarrassed i wasn't
gonna tell eddie
he's a [__] master i'm gonna call
eddie and go i joined the geek class
today [__] i didn't tell
nobody you know first yeah you gotta
i think that listen i'm not a writer
but every day i try to write yeah you
journal right
i journal but i you know i'm not a great
writer i
i wish i could [__]
be like stephen king and write a book a
year and you know
right all that stuff all that stuff
typewriter or
a queer link pen you know i can see with
that but
you know what every [__] day forget
the pen i'm with a feather with ink
you know exactly [__] ink and [__]
but you know there's so many things i
wanted to do
in life you know the other day when i
went to the city
and i was thinking about my childhood
dream and how i got into all this
it was by me seeing a guy named michael
corin his freshman year
come out on the uh it was uh you know
march madness and he played for north
carolina and he was a freshman from
jersey city
and i had no idea i was just watching
the game to watch a championship game
and when they announced jersey city
my insides crumbled he let me know
that i could be on that stage someday
because
it turns into north bergen yes so i'm
like and he's from the projects
his mom raised him he had no dad uh
sport magazine did a ride up on him on
his mother rosie
how she worked in a diner to support him
and to send them to hudson catholic the
school he went to
that's what inspired me to i i
i wanted my friends to feel what i felt
that day when it said from jersey city
new jersey starting forward
number 31 michael i wanted them to you
know from north bergen
joey that was for me that's what i
wanted on a personal note
i got that already you know now i got a
bucket list like everybody else i've
been playing the guitar lately
i don't want to join a band or nothing
like that i just like playing it to
relax
you know that was on my bucket list
thank god
mike made my dream come true because i
would never have the balls
to go buy a guitar did he bring it over
yeah yeah
wow i would i used to walk into guitar
center and [__] have a nervous
breakdown that was
some people like museums you know some
people i love bart music
go [__] yourself me nice guitar we used
to go to we used to get stone
me mitch hedberg you know because we
used to all live
across the guitar center and it was next
to the sunset grill
the song the eagles wrote about you know
down
it's not the same the guy with the
wooden leg died there was a guy with a
wooden leg he made hamburgers
he would come over limping to you he
made the best [__] hamburger that's
where
don henley got it from but then he sold
they fixed it up they cleaned it up but
the guitar center
you were allowed to go in there and play
drums
and guitar and [__] i never touched a
guitar i was never disrespectful
you don't want to be the guy who's just
sort of like fiddling with it yeah yeah
no
i'm not a [__] jerk off like that i
didn't want to touch nobody's guitar
i don't know nothing about guitars i
looked at them in the hall i saw flying
bees
right all this [__] and then all the
tricks yeah but then the guy asked me do
you want to play the drums
they have like a little station on the
side and i [__] around with the drums
and he goes you're not bad you should
keep doing it do you have lessons here
hey
i can't even afford the shirt on my back
never mind [__] messes
you know i actually play the drums do
you still
i do well well the thing is like in it's
weird i found this
almost similar to losing concerts during
the pandemic like now that i'm doing the
apartment living the drums was just
it just naturally ended you know and uh
that's one of my passions that i'm
really itching to get back to but it's
so
you know maybe talking about not knowing
where to start it's like do i get an
electronic kit
do i try to get a studio space it's like
you know we i think we all have those
those moments where it seems like a big
there's so many options you know with
the passion
what are you doing now right now um
well i actually started working for
watch mojo on youtube
um so basically i started off doing a
podcast for them as along with the
podcast that i've already been doing
throughout the years
and uh basically it just sort of went
from just hosting to you know my title
now as a coordinator
uh so you know doing other things for
the company uh interviewing people
setting things up and uh it's crazy man
because i
i just did a podcast about it recently
like just about a year ago
i was washing dishes at a restaurant and
just the mental like difficulty
and like sort of the demoralization of
that knowing that i could achieve more
and getting from that point to here has
like changed my life like it's made me
like a different person
you know it's uh
you know i feel like everybody has to be
very grateful for what they have and
it's like
to be working in podcasting on any level
that's maybe one percent of the world
but to be working in podcasting
not to be you not to be rogan that's
less than one percent
you know what i mean listen uh the joint
isn't what the church was
you know and i and i come to grips with
that and i'm not upset or anything this
is a new beginning for me
you know so but i am very lucky that i
have been podcasting for 10 years
you know and uh i love doing it i know
what i'm doing
and it feels great but i wash dishes
it was humbling i wash dishes in prison
there you go
that's 35 cents an hour you know what
i'm saying that's when you know
you're ain't [__] you know and then i
before that i wash dishes for john
denver at his restaurant
up in aspen i forget the snowmass
village
but i used to wash dishes and i remember
as i was washing them
thinking about building character like
this is 83
when i would wash i would wash dishes on
tuesday nights
it was prime rib night i took the job
because the chef
like me and he goes i'll give you all
the mistakes i was lifting weights so i
like prank i would eat
19 of those prime ribs with horseradish
every night
then i would steal a pound of shrimp no
i only worked tuesdays
and then they said you know coming
thursdays for lobster night
right so i was going on thursdays good
night yeah i had the good nights but
i still remember washing dishes and
being proud
yes like i told people i'm washing
dishes part time
at whatever and they would go but you're
an electrician in the daytime who gives
a [__]
it's ten bucks an hour and they feed me
i don't have to buy groceries
i have to buy groceries that's a pretty
good deal at the time you know and i
would take a pound of shrimp
at home at night and i'd take a shower
and i'd [__] do my little shrimp
cocktail
i was watching usa or whatever the [__]
i was watching
and then i had to wash dishes in prison
and that was
you know he used to [__] abuse me
from time to time i used to have to wash
dishes in the morning and then i'd break
them or i'd break the [__] machine on
purpose
but it buy yourself some time washing
dishes
humbles you oh it does joey and and
just to be clear like when i say i found
it demoralizing
it's not because of washing dishes like
i was trying to be the best dishwasher i
could and
the only reason i had issues with it is
because i worked at a very uppity
restaurant so it wasn't the type of
restaurant where we're all a team
it was the type of restaurant where if
you're doing sort of that type of work
you're like you're worthless
essentially is how you were treated you
know um but what
really what it taught me was not that
it's a bad thing it's like i have more
respect for those people than i ever
thought
i could like the people who actually
commit to doing a good job and they take
pride in going in there every day and
this is their career like it gave me an
appreciation and a respect for that
which like i think that a person needs
you know when a person is doing a job
that's
kind of weird and you meet them
and they start talking to you and
they're really solid people
you really look at that job a lot
differently like you're like wow yeah
you know he's really proud of his job
it's like what's going on now with the
police department you know
everybody's hating on cops listen
there's bad cops
but then there's cops that'll take a
bullet for you are you
that [__] stupid they're cops that
will go into a fire and grab you out of
there that you know
in every field there's good and bad you
know
exactly tend to attract to the you know
i right now i hang out with a detective
in newark and a detective in union
and they i look at them and i admire
them
when they tell me about their jobs and
how they had a homicide
some guy told me they shot a 16 year old
kid in newark last week
but it was you know from a car you know
and he had to go and
and while i was talking to him i was
thinking about walking up on a body
seeing a kid's head blown up you know
that's like
that's what that's like meanwhile you're
over here yelling defund the [__]
police or whatever you know
think about i always think about what
the cops saw
before he came to your house you know
did he see a kid crying and also now he
has to answer a domestic violence call
and you know all the [__] that they see
and
it's called the moment before it's even
used in acting
right like the moment before what was
that person doing before that's why
whenever i look at the scene
i always think all right so before i
walked up on this body what was i doing
before what was i thinking about that i
have an argument
with my wife to have an argument with
somebody else
you know it's like when you're driving
and you cut somebody off and they give
you the finger
you know what just happened to that
person right but just what did he just
go through did his wife just divorce him
did his wife just serve him did he just
find his wife in bed with a [__]
[__]
what what [__] happened you know
could be driving down like why would she
do a [__]
i got a big six-foot dick you know and
then you come pull it up in front of him
yeah and you go like [__] you and what
what's gonna happen the moment before so
it's really it's it's really important
that it's almost like you're dealing
with a different person every day it's
like there's touches of their everyday
personality but it's like the person you
deal with that day is
mostly almost shaped by what has
happened leading up to that day and how
long it's going to take for that to wear
off so yeah it's
very interesting it's interesting that
they would use that in acting like i
would hear gandolfini would like smack
himself in the face before an angry
scene or something and then walk in
there you know like so that makes a lot
of sense
yeah it's the moment before it's like
right now
we have a world that's a little crooked
you know
uh you guys i don't know if you watched
the nba i just
heard a couple weeks that people were
throwing things at players and they got
ejected like sodas and [__]
what yeah yeah two two people got
charged i think it was like two separate
incidents you know
been cooped up i've never thrown a
[__] thing at a professional
basketball player my mom threw chicken
wings at rusty snob but
she was a [__] savage so that was
yeah it was called for he missed the
call and [__] she lost 300 i'll throw
a chicken wing at you too but
i think that right now you really have
to be
very careful with people people have
been in
people have lost jobs people people are
not okay
right now no we're not okay you know
i try to smile everybody i try to wave
at everybody
i try really hard lately because i know
people are hurting i'm hurting
i'm hurting over who knows what you know
whether it's to move
whether it's coming home so
lately i've been very that's why i don't
want to do
up right now right long hiatus but
it's needed man it's needed it's you
know i
you know i need the little break but i'm
already itching
i'm going to watch the show this weekend
some friends of mine are in town
i'm thinking of going to see burke
christian when he comes july 17th
nice you know just to go see them and i
hope that by the time the soprano movie
comes out
i'm well and i could [__] get back on
stage
i don't want to go on stage to [__]
around i want to go on stage to [__]
murder them and i'll tell you what
i'm going to be dirtier than i ever was
that's what i want to hear that's what
i'm talking about i'm not going to go up
there like an
animal and insult different races or
anything like that no
but i gotta talk about what's going on
right now you know that there's a lot to
talk about
yeah there's a lot to talk about i don't
know if you know yesterday i identified
with a seven-year-old kid
you should have seen me had a hat with a
propeller on top you know what i'm
saying
and the day before i i i [__] i was a
horse
you know the day before i ran down the
block with a [__] strat you know you
could identify as anything now you know
what i'm saying so
it's anything anytime right that's
hilarious but so our sopranos movie you
guys were still looking at september
september 24th beautiful very excited
for it
i saw it a couple weeks ago
i really enjoyed it i really enjoyed
what david chase did
i think people are going to enjoy it i
think some of the
knuckleheads might not enjoy it okay
yeah you know everybody misses
gandolfini
you know you don't you don't know how
much you miss gandalfini
till you see gandolfini the other night
i came down here with mercy and we
you know usually at eight o'clock it's
like hey jesse
hey jesse is those two [__] shows
that drive me crazy
but i said it's my daughter i watch him
and as i was scrolling
the drop was on okay with gandolfini
gandolfini in it right and
for two minutes i watched him and i was
like
[__] i miss him and then the next night
i put tv on with mercy again
and he's on killing me softly ah talking
he kept popping up yes yeah
brad pitt and [__] that's a great movie
by the way that's a phenomenal i gotta
check that one out when you see him do
you
are you looking at tony soprano or are
you looking at like jimmy cause you've
talked to you know so many of his
friends and stuff
i never met him but when i see him
i see a great [__] actor yeah
the things i've heard about him have
just been
above and beyond what he did for that
you know you could tell why it was a
great show
yeah you know what he did the type of
person he was the type of character he
was
somebody said something the other day oh
i read an uh uh
uh a meme
from david chase like uh something he
said
in the final scene he touched anthony
and little did he know he goes he didn't
write that he touched anthony's army
oh god and little did he know that was
the last time he was gonna touch his
son's arm my [__] stomach he goes i
didn't say that
but that was the type of guy he was you
know when you watched that show
he was such a you know god had to take
him listen
when you think now god had to take him
because he was too big of a [__]
he was just an animal he was just i i
feel bad saying that but he was
such a star he was i think he was even
surprised as to how big it became it
became bigger than him it was like a
an entity it the energy he gave
off their that show was tremendous you
know
and uh i wish he's in heaven you know i
guess she's looking down and uh
but i watched another show that i
followed the mayor of eatontown
did you watch that i didn't see that one
kate winslet
oh i love acting i love yeah i love
watching great acting
i'm not an actor you know i took a
couple lessons and i [__]
you're an actor get out of here no no
trust me when you work with actors
you're like holy [__] i better [__]
get my game up
you know what i'm saying because this
guy's doing this this guy's doing that
and it's uh kate winslet
just destroyed me with this seven
seven-episode show she did
you know because she went in she went in
there and when i heard that
there's a sex scene and they showed like
she's chubby and the director she told
director to leave the scene in
that's an actor because it's real it's
real
it's wrong it's raw no makeup
you know she only wore makeup when she
went on a date on the show
you know i enjoyed this show i just i
referred
the show to a brother of mine mercy's
godfather he called this morning
when i got out of the doctor's office
and we were talking about the show and
he goes she's
phenomenal i love watching good acting
me too it's amazing i watched i watched
the magnificent 70 all night
[__] charles bronson was yoked
he was a big guy he was a big guy then
you know
death wish was on the other night i've
been watching you know i don't watch
daytime tv
i refuse to put the tv on the daytime no
more news since i
moved to jerry i never watched i'd never
put the tv on during the pandemic
except hey i commend you you know it's a
horrible thing to do
i got hooked on the 3 30 evening news
abc
wide whatever and that really [__] me
up
that got into my psyche in a horrible
horrible way
you know uh i thought i was a lot
stronger than that
but obviously i'm not the when i moved
here i stopped watching the news
and my i changed a lot i could see that
it had contaminated me
you know and it's something that
i looked at it for knowledge of the
virus
right but it wasn't giving you knowledge
of the virus it was
giving you just a negative feeling that
one
yeah i'd watch the news to go smoke a
joint and pop a [__] xanax or ten of
them
because the [__] news was so
disheartening
so the campaign of fear and yeah and
fear yeah and now
i don't have that in my life i don't
know that they have a thing called new
jersey 12 with a gay weatherman i love
him have you seen the guy
he's got like a shitty microphone how
are you doing we're calling
you guys don't wear sandals tomorrow if
you're going to asbury park you know
[__] like that
this guy needs a [__] is his own
primetime show yeah no he's great the
weatherman on new jersey 12 i [__]
love him
but that's it that's still he informs
you that's the thing it's like
the way i see the news is that like and
it's funny because i think that 30 years
ago 25 years ago maybe cnn was the most
trusted name in news or fox or whoever
i'm not biased
against any but it's like i feel like
more of these shows are more so talk
shows
with opinions it's like at a certain
point they're not informing you about
anything they're just giving you their
opinion on a piece of information so
what's that i was like i don't really
need these people's opinions on it i can
just try to maybe pick
and the way i see it too is like if it's
something that's super serious
i'll hear about it i'll call my aunt
i'll call my mom
i'll call somebody they'll say did you
hear about these new restrictions i'll
hear about it
you know what i mean anything you don't
need to hear about
i think it's just noise you know
something that you don't need is just
going into your head and just
taking up your [__] time and it's
weird i like
60 minutes i love that few minutes yeah
because they capsized the whole week for
me in one hour
of three it's very seldom that i don't
like a story 60 minutes is telling me
i don't mind watching a repeat i get
pissed off in 60 minutes there's a
repeat like i'm like i already watched
this one [__]
give me the new stuff yeah last week
they had the one about the judge in new
brunswick
about a half hour from here that they
killed her husband her son her son or
her husband the judge
and she was it was [__] great but the
puerto rican woman
you know 60 minutes gives me the news
that i need
you know i watch real time with uh
the english dude no the i like bill
maher too he said some interesting stuff
but what's the other guy
that's kind of funny and wacky on hbo
john john oliver oh yes this week with
john oliver i love that guy yeah he's
funny he cracks me the [__] up
i like the uk guys there's a very i
heard you saying on on the last joint
that you would
if you you know made a big sum of money
you go to the uk and do podcasts like
the way that they set up their radio
host they're like you see a guy on a rap
radio show he's dressed like the raptors
it's like they're pimping just like
everybody else out there on the radio
it's crazy i would've gone to the uk set
up a studio
and hired a cameraman
i would have [__] gone to abbey road
you know i went to all the places
i wanted i would love to go to the place
where pink floyd
uh recorded wish you were here
that's the last time they saw sid
barrett when he walked in
wow i'd love to go to judas priest's
neighborhood and take my dick out
and go here's
judas priests and black sabbath
basically have the same neighborhood
they're both from birmingham
birmingham so right uh you know i love
to go to those places and visit
you know i just saw a picture from
ireland
a [__] island that has a [__]
mural
that says free cuba wow
that's it i tell people all the time
that cuban irish have a
a big connection i'm married irish woman
i always loved irish women growing up
we're very close because we're catholic
countries
that makes a lot of sense a lot of the
same core values are there some of the
same core values so
in 1690 there was a battle of the boin
and most of the irish that didn't want
to fight went to cuba that's why there's
so many cubans with irish names john
osaga
you know i went to school with a [__]
kid with a [__] up name i don't want
to say it on here because then he'll get
pissed off
then it reveals them yeah it reveals
them but there was a lot of cuban irish
you know it's weird how you do it 23 and
me
and i got like chinese irish
a little jewish a lot of african you
know my grandmothers were [__]
one of them even banged the chinese guy
which is my love for the chinese
everything yeah and that's the
population of cuba was spain
african chinese irish
then in the 50s the italian i i can't
tell you how many
italian cuban kids there are those
gangsters were banging [__] cuban
women
do it right i'm sort of the same way
i'm i'm was talking about it with my
family recently and yeah there's just
like
sort of so many different things in my
background you know and now let me ask
you this because
this is sort of interests me about you
do you
like i would assume that you relate to
your cuban heritage or or
is it like do you have so much heritage
that you don't really gravitate to one
as many as the others
or is it like a cuban thing
as a cuban man i would have a lot of
faults
i was around a lot of traditional cuban
men when i was a kid
and they all had great qualities
but they had bad qualities jealousy
um
over machismo-ism you know
little things i didn't like so as i grew
up i curbed them back
i curved that stuff back i didn't allow
myself to be jealous
you know men who are jealous of women
when a guy i can't i can't have that
[__]
that's tough i saw mike talking to a
girl who cares
you know what i'm saying people talk
it's if you put your dick in the mouth
then we have a problem yeah people do a
lot worse than talk people
um my machismo had to calm down
that cuban machismo [__] just didn't
work for me sometimes you know it didn't
work for me sometimes
i was a mama's boy you know let's not
let's never forget the fact that
i love women i love women who love
looking at them
i don't care what size they are the
bigger the better the skinnier the
better i love women you know
so i think i borrowed from different
races
i'm like a [__] mutt in my head
you know i'm a catholic and i love
catholicism i went to church this week
but you know what
i do buddhist stuff right
my religion is different i love buddhism
you know a lot of mindfulness stuff
a lot of mindfulness i never converted
but i do meditate from time to time
nice i do believe in karma i do believe
in what they do you know i went to
i took a couple classes at naropa i hung
out there in boulder
i did walking meditation you know it was
like a buddhist
experience yes i didn't go to school
that they had
[__] great speakers and the dalai
lama
showed and you could go you know okay
you know all those great
uh offbeat writers used to go to boulder
and
do lectures there so i respect the
uh buddhist thing i then you have
santeria
which is my original cuban thing on the
side which is like cuban catholicism
right do i agree with all santeria stuff
no but it's gotten me to where it's
gotten me you know do i agree with all
catholicism stuff
no [__] mortal sin if i don't go to
church on sunday go [__] yourself
so do it your own way yeah it's killing
somebody and then not going to church on
sunday
that that's a big difference me not
going to church and me killing somebody
you know where's the parallel
where's the [__] one in between like
you know so
we all have our agreements and
disagreements with whatever religion or
if you're not
religious you know i like some of the
jewish things you know
totally there's stuff you can draw from
in all of them oh my god every religion
you know i'm really tight with ari and
i'm tight with lee
and i always ask him questions about
judaism you
know and they tell me you know and and
i've always
you know i always for a while i'm like
i'm gonna [__] convert to be a jew
for the longest time i was thinking of
converting yeah when
my mom died and stuff my father was so
into it that i was like you know what i
think i'm going to convert
because you were looking for something
it was time to sort of gravitate towards
right i was pissed at my god right and
i'm uncircumcised so they could still
cut the foreskin
you know i'm saying it
listen you got to show up on an envelope
and a foreskin and they'll take you you
know what i'm saying
that's the admission package those are
the two [__] requirements to convert
to judaism
you got to date a jewish girl you still
got that skin on your dick and you're
[__] you know
and you're off to the races and you're
off to the races so
what's going on in your world beside
that
you know what man just trying to take
all the steps necessary to get to the
next level
you know we talked about acting and just
how crazy that world is
i started in that world and i'm looking
at like i'm doing my first auditions and
stuff this past six months and
i think it was really good for me i
needed something that i hadn't been
doing for so many years to like give me
a new challenge
because i think i i'll be honest with
you joey i got a little carried away
with myself by the time i started with
acting because i figured
okay i'm finally at an agent's office
where's my movie where's my red carpet
you haven't you guys been waiting for me
and i realized quick that's not how it
[__] goes man
you know what i mean and i started
looking into my favorite actors and the
fact that
al pacino didn't get scarface till he
was 35
and you know like this stuff takes years
to build so the point being
i'm just really battening down the
hatches to improve myself and build
and do a million failed auditions and
maybe get my one
and i'm really just looking at life as a
five to ten year plan right now like i
think things will be cracking for me
then and
i'm not attaching myself to i need to be
at this level next year you know what i
mean
that's the stuff i think young people do
you know are you acting
are you actively looking for roles
i am yeah and i mean i'm i'm i'm looking
to get into the music videos for a
little part you know what i mean
short films if i can there's not many
college films where i'm at but
uh you know i want to do that because
like what i realized is if you want to
act like you don't just want to be in
the movies you want to go do theater you
want to do community stuff so it's like
i also learned like what's the
difference between a real actor and some
douchebag that wants to be on a
billboard
i never want to be that guy right you
know what i mean so it's like it's about
taking those steps so
yeah just actively trying to do it and
it took like actually doing these
auditions and stuff like i always
appreciated the guys like gandolfini and
looked up to them with wide eyes but
then when i even started trying to do
one iota of a facial expression of a guy
like that in an audition that's when it
really hit me like a ton of bricks like
oh this is
this is a lifestyle thing like this is
something people are born to do
and then other people can kind of maybe
do it so uh yeah it's just
i'm just trying to be better joey you
know i i just wanted to get better
that's we all are and it's contagious
you know i i
i enjoy doing the podcast because i've
been trying to work on myself since i
landed in this [__] state
yeah and people are seeing that i don't
want to lead by talking [__] i want to
lead by them
watching me making the change i told you
i was going to slow down on the reefer
i told you i needed to lose weight i
told you i needed to journal more to
figure out what this anxiety i had was
coming from
i'm always trying to better myself in
any
single way possible you know especially
with a daughter
you want to give her all the knowledge
absolutely you know she brought her
homework down yesterday
i got to be honest with you i would have
got an
f plus octagons and four sides and
i don't remember none of that [__] but
you know you got to be involved
and uh that's that's what this whole
thing is about you know
this whole pandemic if by july of last
year
you didn't look at this and go okay
there's a pandemic they
took my job mike can't go do his open
mic
you know there's so many things we
couldn't do let's
focus on what we can do exactly you can
still run
you could still write you could still
ride your bike
you can still play the game turn on a
webcam you know turn on a webcam
there were so many ways to improve
yourself and i said this to myself like
in
you know because we were all waiting for
the pandemic to end and we didn't know
when it was going to end
i made one goal and i'll take the
notebook out and look for it
i said i want one positive thing out of
this pandemic
just one i want to be i want to come out
of this i think that everybody should
have came out of this
with one pant one goal out of this
pandemic a dear friend to
me the other day that all he kept
hearing was the disease and how bad it
was the covet but
nobody in america was telling people to
take care of themselves
yeah listen this is what you need to be
doing take the vitamin d
the magnesium get your eight hours of
sleep this is the first time
a lot of us have had this break you know
people are changing careers
people it's insane it's insane it's
insane you gave america
you gave the world the chance to think
and look at themselves through a [__]
microscope
and now we know what we want to do i in
turn acted last week
and i got to tell you i [__] fell in
love with it where'd you go
all right in the city okay was it with
vinnie or
huh was it with vinnie p no no no i
when i got here i contacted an agent i
had
from l.a that was now here booking
theater which i'm going to
nice call him this afternoon and tell
him to start looking for a couple plays
for me
like 90 seat theater because i think i
want to commit
i think i want to commit you know people
want to see it people want to hear you
you know i want to be part of a play i i
don't
listen when you join the there's a
couple group theater groups around here
and i've been going on their websites
okay you know you got to clean bathrooms
you got to sweep one month you take
tickets at the door
one month you do the lights one month
you clean the bathrooms you know what
bro
i'm never [__] too good to clean a
[__] bathroom it's like a company
[Music]
so i'm either thinking of doing a local
theater
i want to see what new york i mean new
york right now is not the place to
be jumping up and down at night yet
let's let it settle a little bit
if you could find the theater group
around here that'll take me because i'm
a [__] hack
comic actor you know what i'm saying
like it's not like please it's not like
i'm there
quoting stanislavski or whatever
well we have that in common yeah it's
not like but i have read on acting
and i will tell you something and i tell
you this with all my heart caches and
you know
i'm the type of guy that people say [__]
about me and i
disagree with them but i will tell you
this
when it comes to auditioning i don't
know too many people better than me
i'm better at auditioning than stand-up
comedy
wow because mitzi shaw used to make you
do three minutes
no at the store three minutes three
minutes three minutes three minutes
you know how many comics have quick
comedy because they couldn't do three
minutes
probably so many you have to tell your
story
in three [__] minutes so i never
really put it together when i started
going out for auditions like you
oh i would bomb every other [__]
audition
every audition thank you for coming
you're
great you know what i'm saying that was
phenomenal
yeah thank you and you're like you want
me to read it again no no no no
no not really leave and then you walk
out of there i had a lot of those you
know
and then one day i took a cold reading
workshop
and uh it was by the guy that
did sleepers okay
and godfather too wow and he
changed me his audition system
he wanted you to be aggressive i would
walk into auditions very timidly hi how
are you
but then i started listening to those
jerk offs in la
they would walk into a class like hi
hi cassius oh my god we have a mutual
friend michael listen you're still not
getting the wrong [__]
so why are you dropping michael's name
for get out of the way i was not talking
your way into this
dawg i was on audition once where chick
brought a tray of brownies for the
casting director
oh you know when they tell you
dress up like the character if you
actually go dressed up like the
character
you're not gonna get the right i've
heard that's a bad one that's a bad one
like me and ari got a call one day
harry calls you in the morning he's like
did you get an audition tiger yeah
they wanted me to dress up like a
colonial [__] soldier oh [__] you
i went in there with a yankee had on
there like where's your [__]
you know kentucky fried chicken suit
[__] you who's gonna imagine it
that's what that's power that's what
they do to you
i used it differently i used to like if
i went for a mob
tv show i wore a white shirt
okay a mob commercial white dress shirt
movie mafia roll gray shirt or black
shirt
wow interesting what was that i just
want you to oh like when i got
basketball i was a ref correct
so i wore a shirt with strings
okay so it looked like a whistle but you
didn't wear an actual whistle that's the
beauty of it
no right no right that's a good one
you don't go with it's like comics with
comedy club send me a tape i send blank
tapes
i sent blank tapes for years tapes yeah
because they don't watch them right
that's control oh yeah you go to you go
to get paid on saturday
they got stacks of tapes with dust on
them
wow and i'm like hey that dude is really
funny and the guy would look at it and
go i haven't had a chance to look at the
tape no [__] it's got six inches of dust
on it
so all that is a control [__] like you
could call
the same club owner 15 times go hi my
name is cassius morris
i like to work your club i haven't
looked at your tape yet but
cassius could talk to joey by mistake be
talking to him and go
i'm trying to get in that [__] wise
guys in utah
and the guy won't [__] take me and
also and i call you and you're my
feature
right and yeah this is how it goes i
tried to get in to catch a rising star
for years
for years they had vegas some other
[__] joint reno and new jersey
okay three years i tried to get in there
one day i got a call from jimmy schubert
you want a feature for me
um he's about the relationship yeah it
was you know
15 years ago jimmy took me up there as a
feature and then i started headlining
for the catcher rising star so
you can't get mad at things you have to
let things work themselves out
organically
you i gotta tell you man for a young man
you have done a great job a lot of thank
you
i mean when did we do our first podcast
eight nine years ago
seven years ago yeah well maybe and yeah
you're still going on ten yeah going on
ten
you're still how old are you now i'm 22.
jesus christ you drink no
actually i was you know but i actually
not right now okay good good i don't
rule it out for the future but i'm at a
point where like my job is
it's more like organization scheduling
spreadsheets like
i'm my hosting is actually more so on
the side and it's more so coordinating
so it's like
i just really looked in the mirror when
i came into this new place and i was
like
okay you watch motivational videos from
you know this guy this guy this guy
would they have [__] old milwaukees
on their desk
would they have a [__] rick and morty
bong in the corner no
so okay screw off then and that was it
you know that was it i know you're on uh
i know you gotta
do your gig this afternoon uh no no i'm
good joey i'm good
okay i wanted to let these guys know
that you know
i got a lot of 40 year olds and 30 year
olds that follow me and ask me questions
and they're
confused about you know things and i'm
happy that
i have a 22 year old here that's been
committed to something for 10 years
when you're 12 most kids can't commit to
dick except [__]
texting and roller skating or whatever
the [__] they do
at 12 you already were like a young man
and now you're a man you know i know you
got a girlfriend i know you
you're making moves and stuff like that
so
i'm really proud of you thank you the
people that listen to this podcast today
or watch this i wish that follow cassius
you know i follow them and sometimes i
write something for you sometimes i
don't but i want you to know i'm always
watching
and i'm always very proud of you when i
saw
rob halford on your [__] podcast
you know listen a guy like me
would say [__] him he's got rob outfit
let me tell you something i was so
[__] happy for you
oh that means the world man i was so
happy for you because i know how hard
you've been working
you know dean delray when he got brian
johnson oh
i was crying for him people don't same
with me i was so happy for him i wasn't
mad at wishing it was me you know
you you when you start cheering for
people
is when your life changes i see all
these people on the internet that
every time somebody puts something up
positive they got a [__] on it
yeah and they wonder why they have
shitty lies
the first thing i do when i wake up in
the morning is i go to facebook
and i see if i know anybody's birthday
and then i find somebody i don't know
and i wish him a happy birthday
yeah that starts my day off on a
positive note i made somebody's day
at 7 30 in the [__] morning without
leaving the house
gonna look at their [__] page and go
that fat [__] joey diaz said no
he's got an assistant that did it you
know whatever
it was me but that's how my day starts
that's
i'm giving love you know and even once
that goes into the subconscious that's
still working for you that's still out
there you know it works any anybody when
you wake up from now on
go to [__] facebook and look at the
birthdays
find the [__] find the ugliest
dude you know that nobody's [__]
inviting them nowhere
it feels good happy birthday see how
good you're gonna [__] feel
and i mean who knows you could be the
only person to wish him a happy birthday
that day
and you might stop him from his himself
you might stop you know birthdays are
shitty days for some people they think
back to where was i last year at this
time you know i'm just saying
but that's the first thing i do every
morning
is wish somebody a happy birthday that's
a [__] stranger
yeah because i want my day to go off the
right way that's what it's all about
that's what we're here to do is making
people's day caches and i know
you do it and i do it i love you yeah
i'm happy you had a chance to to uh
call in today and talk with me and hang
out
it's always a pleasure and i gotta tell
you something i'm very
very very proud of you oh thank you and
i can't wait
to [__] retire from podcasting to
pass my little [__] thing on to you
you know
because you are the next joe rogan in
eight years
oh my joe's getting old oh my god mark
marion's getting old
bill burr is getting old they're all
getting old and
by the time in eight years you'll be
podcasting 16 years
yeah that's great that's crazy to think
about that that's really crazy to think
about so the throne belongs to you
you might not see it yet you might sit
there going oh my god
joe rogan is great yeah jay williams
getting older and shorter and i'm
getting older and fatter
and [__] bill burr is getting funnier
and older he just gets funnier bill
burke yeah bill burr is his time
[__] just gets funny he's
timeless
uh so along the line and everybody's
getting
you know theo all those guys are [__]
moving on
so i predict in eight years
you'll be the [__] new howard stern
if you want it did you even get ace
freely
yes yeah actually he [__] made a
bulldozer
revelation on my show did he really yeah
he premiered his political beliefs uh
just out of nowhere on my show and then
it became a massive
thing but uh man that that [__]
man i love that guy
i love him such a good guy he just moved
to jersey
wow okay i could see that definitely he
lives in jersey you gotta get him on the
podcast listen
i would cut my finger off to get a
guitar lesson from him everybody knows
he's a great guy
we need a video of that oh my god i
would die if i saw ace freely first off
i think he's the funniest man in the
world
he's amazing he could i think he could
destroy
chris rock destroy dave chappelle
i've seen his interviews he is a riot i
think he is one of the funniest men i've
ever been around him i never met him
i've never had the chance to talk to him
so
just for that i give you kudos i think
he's the funniest [__] around
he is just incredible man and like just
the fact that he was so down to earth
like i interviewed him once before on
the phone
and it was he was doing a big press day
and my questions weren't that great i
was young
but then we did this one man and it was
just like shooting the [__] with a
friend and
and you know like just the fact that it
happened like obviously would mean so
much to anybody but
i wasn't around man like when destroyer
came out like i wasn't
i was it was great that's what i mean
and it was great but it's like this is
the closest
i'll actually ever get to even their
prime so it's like that's
extra layer of appreciation that's the
thing i nev this [__] never goes over my
head i'm never like oh yeah that's
of course i did that no [__] that it's
like people would you know
there's people out there that that makes
their day just the fact that i did it so
i appreciate every second man
honestly i love you little brother joey
thank you so much man
thank you congratulations on doing
everything that you've done and
i see big things coming your way and all
i want you to do is when you get your
big howard stern studio and
the whole thing to have a little picture
of me on the side saying that
[__] is my brother right there
that's all i want from you
you know i always will i have the
painting in my house and that painting
will be in my home for the rest of my
life joey every single day
i love you brother thank you for coming
hey thanks michael stay in touch give
your parents my best
absolutely all right i will suck up to
your family as well you got it love you
love you bye-bye all right you bad
[__] that was cassius morris
don't forget to watch his podcast
listen to his podcast i don't know what
the name of it is watch mojo
watch mojo uh on youtube he's a great
kid
and uh he's one of us he's just
nobody knows who he is but he's gonna
creep up on you and i guarantee you
within 10 years
you'll be on this dick [__] just
like anybody else
uh it's been a great week it really has
whether it's on patreon or whatever
i put that picture up of me as a
nine-year-old you [__] went
nuts
with my little cuban suit on and [__]
you couldn't believe my mom dressed me
up like that that's
that's the way i was when i was a kid i
was never dressed and my mother saw me
now she ripped his shirt off me
my mother saw how i dress now she ripped
half my clothes
do you know that i put a church shirt on
that has a rip
up here and i went to my daughter's
softball practice and when i got home i
looked in the mirror and i did exactly
what my mother would do
i just ripped it i just ripped down to
the bottom go put a new [__] shirt on
you pig walking around with that shirt
on with a hole in it i work [__] 90
hours a week so you could have a hole in
your [__] shirt
you piece of [__] but anyway
flashback flashbacks you know how it is
sometimes you got to drop it on you
[__] i love you guys
thank you very much for supporting us
thank you very much for watching us
uh we're only going to get better and
better i'm only going to get better and
better we're going to get stronger
we're going to get mike in this thing
involved we're going to get him a
computer [__] alert
looking up [__] and we're gonna add more
elements to this [__] show
thank you thank you very much for always
having my back thank you for supporting
us
thank you for watching and thank you for
watching uh
cassius and you're going to enjoy them
all right stay black have a great
weekend and now
for a word for my [__] sponsors
all right it's wednesday i want to thank
cassius one more time for coming on i
hope you guys enjoyed them i love the
kid with all my heart
but anyway the joint is brought to you
by cbd
lion the best when it comes to cbd how
do i know
because i know people have sent me
thousands of different cbd
creams and [__] cbd lion is what's
worked to me
and i have 20 different uses for it
whether it's the tape
the extra strength cream the bath balls
the hemp flour listen
the hem flour is really good and it's
very helpful in a lot of ways
somebody referred it to me years ago i
thought they were crazy it's [__]
great they have vapor pens cartridges
but it all starts with you
to go onto cbdlion.com and reading
read the benefits and advantages of cbn
cby
and cbd go to cbd line
find something you like it they're going
to take care
they're going to give you 20 off when
you put in joey
or church it's that simple cbd lion the
real deal
when it comes to cbd the joint is also
brought to you by
zip recruiter good help is hard to find
it's like trying to find you know
a homeless person in [__] new jersey
you're not gonna find one
you could always post your job online or
at the [__] liquor store wall
or at some [__] community wall but
then you gotta sit and hope that the
right person walks by and sees it
you don't want that stop dreaming come
on try zip recruiter for free
again try ziprecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
joey you know why because they do the
work for you with
one click listen to me one click your
job gets sent to over a hundred
top job sites and here's where it gets
[__] freaky here
their matching technology hooks you up
with the people with the skills and
experience that you need
get a qualified candidate fast let them
play matchmaker
so you have more time to focus on your
business
zip recruit is so effective that four
out of five employers
who use zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day
you'll be sitting there for two weeks on
your hands waiting like [__] you know
the law waiting for somebody 2.3 million
businesses have already used
ziprecruiter
whether you've got 200 employees or five
employees
zip recruiter is for you why miss out
while other companies overwhelm you with
too many options
zipper crew defines what you're looking
for that little [__] pebble on the
[__] beats that nobody's seeing
right now today wednesday the 16th you
can try zip recruiter for free
troy what are you talking about free
free okay
at ziprecruiter.com show you again
that's ziprecruiter.com
joey you can try it for free zip recruit
is going to help you save
time money and energy and get you a
qualified candidate
so you can take care of your [__]
what you need to
so try it for free just by going to
slash ziprecruiter.com zip recruiter the
smartest way to hide i want to thank zip
recruiter
i want to thank cbd lion i want to thank
draftkings
i want to thank bluechu i want to thank
all our sponsors this week for having
our back
but most importantly i want to thank you
guys for always being here
on mondays and wednesdays and supporting
us you guys know we're trying our
[__] best
and we give it to you straight from the
[__] heart i love you guys stay
black
and if you need more joey dears go to
patreon.com
joey diaz three five ten dollars and if
these coming
mugs are coming what the [__] knows i
love you guys see you monday tip top
magoo have a great weekend
stay black
you